On the 13th of April 1970, three astronauts
were broadcasting back to earth, beaming a rare,
live look inside a spaceship on one of
the most important missions in history.
Jim Lovell, Jack Swigert, and Fred
Haise were heading for the moon,
where, if all went to plan, Lovell and
Haise would become the fifth and sixth
humans to walk on its surface.
All three were in high spirits,
chuckling and chortling for the camera -
even playing practical jokes on each other.
Back on earth at Mission Control in Houston,
Texas, the mood was equally buoyant. The
first 55 hours had gone so smoothly that
Capsule Communicator Joe Kerwin carped that he
and the rest of the team were bored to tears.
In hindsight, tempting fate with practical
jokes and talk of boredom was a bad idea.
Because if there's one place you don't want to
dare the universe to make an example of you,
it's in a tiny spaceship 200,000 miles from home.
Lovell closed the broadcast by wishing
the people of earth a pleasant evening,
sporting a beaming grin on his face.
However, it didn’t stay there for long.
Because shortly after, Jim Lovell, Jack
Swigert, and Fred Haise were fighting for
their lives in a crippled spaceship that seemed
certain to become their cold, cramped coffin.
The question on their - and everyone else's -
lips was simple: would they make it home alive?
This is the remarkable story of the most
magnificent mishap in the history of space flight.
This is Apollo 13.
It's easy to assume that the eyes of
the world were on the crew of Apollo
13 as they blasted off from the Kennedy
Space Centre in Florida. But the truth is,
most people didn't even know
the launch was happening.
Apollo 13 was to be the fifth manned mission
to the moon, and its astronauts would be the
third crew to step foot on its surface - what
would be huge news today was *old* news in 1970.
As a result, that broadcast I just
mentioned - the one that should have
given the public an incredible insight
into life on a space shuttle heading to
the moon - not a single station picked it
up, and it was never actually shown on TV.
If it *had* been, those who watched would
have witnessed the stillness before space
exploration's most severe storm. Because,
within 6 and a half minutes of the Apollo
13 crew waving goodbye to an absent audience,
a large chunk of their spacecraft exploded.
A loud bang bellowed and scores
of warning lights simultaneously
blinked on. It was Jack Swigert
who first reported the bad news
to Mission Control in what is now one
of the most famous quotes in history:
“Houston, we have a problem…”
...Except, that isn't actually
what he said. Swigert's
actual proclamation was the pronouncedly less
pithy - 'Okay, Houston, we've had a problem here.'
The misqoute was made famous by the
1995 film 'Apollo 13,' but it wasn't
so much a mistake as a deliberate
rewriting of history. The modified
line - particularly the change from past to
present tense - was deemed more dramatic.
Anyway, the exact wording doesn't
matter. What mattered was that the
crew of Apollo 13 were now officially fucked.
So many of the spaceship's systems went south
so swiftly that the guys in Mission Control
assumed their instruments were playing
up. Jim Lovell had another theory - he
thought they'd been hit by a meteor.
As it happens, they were both wrong - a
faulty wire had caused an explosion that
destroyed the ship's vital oxygen tanks.
Short of the insta-death of a decompression
incident, it was just about the worst possible
thing that could happen. It wasn't just that the
crew needed oxygen for, you know, not dying - the
ship did, too. The Apollo 13 command module -
which housed the crew's accommodation and many
of the ship's critical systems - was powered
by 3 electrochemical fuel cells, and the cells
themselves were fed by a combination of hydrogen
and oxygen. No oxygen meant no electricity,
and no electricity meant almost nothing
in the entire command module would work.
Before the explosion, the Apollo 13 crew had been
speeding towards the moon and a place in history.
After it, they were scrambling simply to survive.
The first and most pressing obstacle to overcome
was the minor concern that the
oxygen was about to run out.
The Apollo 13 spacecraft was split into three
parts - the command module, the service module,
and the lunar module. Without power the
command module was essentially dead,
and the service module, which housed the
recently exploded oxygen tanks and other
consumables - contained no living space. That
left the lunar module - the craft that would have
taken Lovell and Haise down to the surface of the
moon had the mission not gone to absolute shit.
The lunar lander was a tight fit
for three grown men and it hadn’t
been designed for prolonged occupation - it didn't
even have seats and in places its outer
shell was less than a millimetre thick.
That was the bad news. But the good news was
life saving - the lunar module was essentially a
self-contained unit - it had its own life support
system and was powered by dedicated batteries.
With oxygen - and therefore power -
rapidly depleting in the command module,
the astronauts made a mad dash for the
lunar module. Swigert stayed behind to
shut down the sundry electrical systems to
save what little power was left (they were
going to need it if they ever made it back to
earth), while Lovell got to work transferring
vital navigational data from the computer in the
command module to the one in the lunar module.
Unfortunately for Lovell, the computers
used different coordinate systems,
so he was forced to do some on-the-fly algebra
to convert between the two. Considering any
errors would likely have meant death
for him and his friends, it was a bit
like doing an undergraduate mathematics exam
while the universe held a gun to his temple.
Luckily, Lovell was an absolute badass
and he passed with flying colours.
For the next three and a half days, the lunar
module would become the astronaut's lifeboat
in the sea of space - a tiny oasis in
the deadliest desert in the universe.
But while the immediate
'oh-shit-we're-all-about-to-die' danger had
passed, there was still the small matter of how
the hell they were going to get home - remember,
at this point in the mission they were still
speeding away from Earth towards the moon.
The most obvious course of action was
to fire the main thruster to turn the
ship around. It was the fastest way to get
home, but it was also risky. It would mean
draining most of the remaining power from the
command module's fuel cells, and even worse,
the thruster was located on the recently
exploded service module. Neither the crew
nor mission control had any way of knowing
whether it'd been damaged in the blast.
In a worst case scenario, firing it could have
blown the entire ship into a million pieces.
That was far from ideal, so NASA's best and
brightest came up with a radical plan B.
You see, the service module wasn't the only part
of the ship equipped with a thruster - the lunar
module had one too, designed to control the
lander’s descent down to the surface of the
moon. It was significantly less powerful
than the main thruster so an immediate
u-ie was impossible. But it did have enough
power to nudge the ship's course just enough
to put it on an earth-reentry trajectory after
slingshotting around the moon. It would be much
slower than an immediate abort using the main
thruster, but it was also significantly safer.
The decision ultimately lay with Flight
Director Gene Kranz, and after careful
consideration he placed his bet on the
tortoise rather than the hare. As Apollo
13 swung around the far side of the moon,
the crew performed a 34 second burn of the
lunar module's descent propulsion system to
put the craft back on a reentry trajectory,
followed by a second, longer burn to speed
up the journey home by around 12 hours.
That last part was crucial, because
time was most certainly of the essence.
Plan B may have avoided the possible
game over screen of firing the
potentially-damaged main thruster. But
it came with grave dangers of its own.
The lunar module was designed to accommodate two
astronauts on the surface of the moon for about
2 days. But after its entirely unexpected career
change from lunar lander to long term lifeboat,
it was going to have to support *3*
astronauts for 3 and a half days.
You don’t have to be pythagoras to
see that those sums didn't add up,
and every single consumable resource - energy,
food, water, and oxygen - would have to be
stretched to the absolute limit if the crew were
to stand any chance of returning to terra-firma.
## Energy
The lunar module had its own batteries, but
they'd never been intended for such prolonged
use. If they died, so too would the crew. So
all non-essential systems were shut down,,
reducing energy consumption to
about one fifth of its typical rate.
Problem was, the ship's electrical systems
also happened to be an important source of
passive heat. With most of them powered
down the temperature inside the ship
plummeted to just 3 degrees Celsius
- about what you'd find in a fridge.
## Food and Water
For the most part food wasn't an issue. The crew
still had access to the crippled Command Module,
where there was plenty of grub floating around
- literally - although some of it froze.
Water was a different story. There
was a small portable reserve aboard,
but most of it was supposed to be
made along the way as a byproduct
of reactions in the ship's fuel
cells - you know, the broken ones.
Many of the ship's critical systems
relied on water-cooling. So,in an
effort to make sure there was enough of
the wet stuff for both man and machine,
the astronauts were put on a water
ration of just 200 ml per person per day.
## Oxygen
Surprisingly, oxygen wasn’t actually a concern.
Despite being designed for a two-day stay on
the moon, the Lunar Module had contingency
built in, which included a large quantity
of excess oxygen. Unfortunately, the crew also
had an excess of something much less desirable.
About a day and a half after relocating into
the lunar module, yet another warning light
started blinking: the carbon dioxide
level was getting dangerously high.
The lunar module was equipped
with a CO2 filtration system,
but like everything else it hadn't been
designed for such prolonged and intensive use.
The system relied on canisters of
CO2-scrubbing lithium hydroxide pellets,
but they could only absorb so
much before becoming saturated.
Luckily there were plenty of spare canisters
in the command module - un-fucking-luckily,
they were square shaped, and incompatible with
the round filter housing in the lunar module.
In hindsight, that was a huge oversight - there
was no reason whatsoever for the canisters to
be incompatible across the two modules. But
it was far too late for finger pointing, if
they didn't find a solution fast Lovell, Swigert,
and Haise were dead men walking… well, floating.
It was a life or death situation, but it was
also kind of hard not to appreciate the irony
of NASA being forced to focus the combined
brainpower of its most brilliant engineers
on the age-old problem of trying to
fit a square peg into a round hole.
The solution they came up with was suitably
ingenious. Limited only by what would be available
to the astronauts, they hashed out a design
for a filter adapter using a space suit hose,
several plastic sample bags, cardboard torn
from logbook covers, and a rolled up sock.
The ridiculous contraption was held
together with duct tape and looked
about as sophisticated as a crackhead in drag,
but as soon as the astronauts finished putting
it together the CO2 level began to drop.
Despite having once again successfully managed
to not die, things were going from bad to worse.
The crew were forbidden from venting urine
out into space for fear the tiny jets of
wee would propel the craft off course. And
after several days peeing in plastic bags,
there were pouches of piss all over the place.
In summary, Lovell, Swigert, and
Haise were cold, they were dehydrated,
and they were perpetuallyassaulted by
plastic pockets of their own piss. But
if Lovell and his crew thought
their luck was about to change,
they were mistaken. Because as earth grew
ever larger outside the spacecraft’s windows,
Mission Control got in touch with yet more bad
news - they'd drifted off course. Instead of
penetrating earth's atmosphere as intended, they
were going to bounce off it like a skimming stone.
If that happened there would be no
second chances - the spaceship would
become their tomb and their frozen corpses
would remain in a loose orbit around earth
for thousands - perhaps millions - of years.
Now, I know what you're thinking - they'd already
corrected their course once, why not just do it
again? Unfortunately, it wasn't that easy. The
previous course correction had levraged the
moon’s gravity in tandem with the thrusters.
This time - so close to earth and without the
moon's gravity to help out - they were going
to have to take matters into their own hands,
literally. They powered down the guidance
computer (aka sat nav) to the ship’s
location was basically unknown, then,
they grabbed hold of the controls and,
using the sun as a reference point,
manually lined the ship up for reentry.
This was entirely unchartered territory - no
crew had ever attempted anything like it before.
Get it wrong, and they would be
dead. Get it right and... well,
they still might be dead. But
at least they'd have a chance.
5 hours before scheduled reentry into
earth's atmosphere, Mission Control
gave them the go ahead to execute the burn.
Under unimaginable pressure, Lovell, Swigert,
and Haise pulled off the unprecedented manoeuvre
perfectly. So perfectly, in fact, that by the
time they shut off the thrusters, they were within
half a degree of their intended angle of approach.
Apollo 13 was coming home.
The lunar module had served the astronauts
remarkably well over the past three and a half
days, but the time had come to leave it behind.
Because only one part of the Apollo spacecraft
was capable of withstanding the enormous
temperatures of reentry - the command module.
There was of course one slight problem with that
- the crippled command module had been powered
down three and a half days earlier. Engineers on
the ground had spent the intervening time trying
to figure out how the hell they were going
to bring it back online again using only the
lunar module's meagre battery. Nobody had ever
powered down a command module in space before,
and the team had to write an entirely new
procedure from scratch. It ran to over 500
individual steps, and it was down to the
absolutely bloody knackered, dangerously
dehydrated Jack Swigert to implement it in the
freezing cold command module with only torchlight
to see by. Just in case that wasn't miserable
enough, any mistake meant almost certain death.
To the immense relief of everyone concerned,
Swigert swaggered his way through the makeshift
process and the wounded Command Module slowly
flickered back to life. With that out of the way
the service and lunar modules were jettisoned off
into space, and Apollo 13 was ready for reentry.
Even then, having come so far and gone through
so much, nobody knew for sure if they’d make it
down to earth in one piece. The key concern was
the heat shield - it had been perilously close
to the site of the oxygen-tank explosion,
and there was no way of knowing if it had
been damaged in the blast. If the heat shield
failed, the astronauts would die a fiery death.
That was surely on their minds as they strapped
themselves in and prepared for the lights to go
up on the final act of the most extraordinary
space opera in history. Would they see their
families again, or were the seconds from an
agonising death? They were about to find out.
Back on earth, Apollo 13 had gone from
a mission nobody really cared about to
the most closely followed in history after
the Apollo 11 moon landing. There had been
round the clock news coverage of the astronauts'
plight, and an estimated 70 million people were
watching events unfold on TV. Many millions
more had their eyes trained on the sky.
Just to ratchet up the tension that
little bit further, there would be a
4 minute radio blackout during reentry
as the immense heat interrupted comms.
The world held its breath as the seconds ticked
down, and when those 4 minutes were finally up
Houston tentatively radioed the command
module… and got no response whatsoever.
A full minute and a half passed
and still there was nothing.
But just when it seemed certain the Apollo
astronauts perished at the very last hurdle,
Jack Swigert's voice crackled into life
on the radio. Apollo 13 had made it.
The command module splashed down in the
South Pacific soon afterwards not far
from American Samoa, where the crew
were picked up by the USS Iwo Jima.
They were cold, they were dehydrated, they were
tired, and they were very, very glad to be home.
Jim Lovell, Jack Swigert, and Fred Haise may
not have walked on the surface of the moon,
but to this day they hold the record for
reaching the greatest distance from Earth
in history. To put that another way, no human
beings before or since have ventured further
away from our home planet than the Apollo 13
astronauts. Even more importantly, those three
men played the starring roles in one of mankind's
greatest triumphs of cooperation and survival.
Thanks for watching.